sí buenas tardes
a ver primero que todo la resolución que
salió hace unos días es basada en la
resolución 215 del año
2021 donde se avala el uso de las que tú
monedas es decir desde el 2021 en cubo
se permite el uso del objeto pero con la
resolución que acabo de salir hace unos
días lo que se hace son unos
lineamientos
de cuáles son los requisitos que las
personas y las plataformas deben cumplir
son varios son aproximadamente 20 puntos
pero lo importante aquí es que se le da
como un paso se le da un permiso a que
todas las personas que quieran
involucrarse y poder vender o poder
operar kryptos lo pueden hacer entre
comillas libremente porque como le digo
hay que cumplir ciertos lineamientos y
de qué manera la crypton edad le puede
servir a cuba para evitar las sanciones
de washington
bueno yo creo que actúa en siles y demás
es a las personas las personas las que
más han sufrido por todas las sanciones
económicas de los últimos años que ha
recibido cuba y a las personas les va a
servir muchísimo para no solamente
intercambiar en sí entre los ciudadanos
de cuba sino también llegar a
relacionarse intercambiar kryptos con
otros países de la región y vemos que en
américa latina a propósito que usted
menciona la región los gobiernos
populistas del salvador y de cuba
impulsan la cripto moneda porque se ve
este fenómeno bajo esas administraciones
bueno vale decir que lo de cuba y lo del
salvador es totalmente diferente es el
salvador coloco comunidad del curso
legal en el pit coin mientras que lo que
está haciendo jugo de darle un permiso a
las personas a que puedan operar
intercambiar libremente y que ellos
mismos puedan en sí generar plataformas
si es diferente es diferente el punto de
vista no sabemos si cual llegaría al
punto de establecer bitcoin como moneda
de curso legal no lo sabemos pero son
dos contextos diferentes y a propósito
de los lineamientos que se conocieron
del banco central cubano esto podría
impulsar de alguna manera la economía de
la isla
bueno podría ser podría ser gracias a
que los cripto activos tienen esa
ventaja de poder ser intercambiables las
24 horas del día y esto podría ser
alguna manera de ayudar a la dina a que
se dinamiza un poco más la economía
cubana es muy temprano porque como como
tú lo decías hasta mayo empezará las
plataformas a operar pero será hacer un
seguimiento yo creo muy adecuado los
siguientes meses para ver cuánta
cantidad de cripto activos se han
movilizado y ver cuál ha sido el impacto
en la economía pero es muy temprano
todavía para poder hacer una afirmación
de cómo podría esto ser impactar en la
economía cubana y haremos precisamente
ese seguimiento yo en torres gracias por
estar con nosotros
bueno muchísimas gracias